a hundred days ago i didn't think this
was possible a hundred videos in a
hundred days
daily uploading
[Music]
it's an absolute insane project
looking back it's even more insane than
i thought
yeah i wanted to talk about it explain
to you guys
what you can get out of it if you decide
to go daily because i realize there's no
real resource for people thinking about
doing this
or wondering you know what are the
benefits if any is it just like
you know a proven formula for creator
burnout like so many of us think
what can you get out of it what did i
get out of it you know i've made over a
little over 100 videos i think i've
uploaded a little bit less
but it all averages out to about 100
videos in 100 days totally bizarre that
we're
here and i've got a lot of thoughts
because it was surprising
in the ways that it was great and also
in the ways like oh i didn't expect
this part to suck so much so to be clear
like one of the reasons i got in was yes
can i do this could i is it possible um
because you know i've been a monthly
uploader in the past like on coffee
break i made a video a month
and i couldn't imagine making more than
that because it was like so
taxing and one of the reasons it was
taxing actually was i had
really bad writer's block no idea is
ever good enough like i would spend
probably two weeks out of the four weeks
um just trying to think of an idea
what's the idea what's the idea and some
of that was productive some of it was
just
unproductive writer's block that is
unhelpful
and i wanted to cure myself of that very
explicitly
and i've never forgotten one podcast
that malcolm gladwell had with
tim ferriss where he talks about the
cure to writer's block
let's take a listen together shall we
because this is pro
number one of going daily you run into
writer's block uh if if so how does that
manifest and what do you what do you do
i don't you know i worked for 10 years
at a newspaper and
if that experience teaches you anything
it's that you can't have writer's block
i mean you
quite literally can't i mean the story
will be you'll start the story at 10 30
and it's
due at 4 00 or 4 30 or whatever back in
those days there was hard deadlines
so you can't have i mean it's nothing
unthinkable i mean you know the luxury
and if you went to your bosses and you
said i'm blocked
on the story they would look at you like
you were insane
you know like take off your beret you've
done your poetry
so it's like there's not even an issue
so i mean i i did
used to have these issues and then i
went to the washington post and you get
cured in a hurry
of any pretensions you have about your
writing that
idea stuck in me for years i mean i
probably heard this when this
when it first came out four years ago
and i had always thought
i have that problem i have writer's
block and i want to cure it
and daily uploading i would tell any
anybody
creative person struggling with any kind
of uh you know
pretensions about themselves you will
cure yourself i
i can say absolutely for sure probably
forever i am cured of writer's block
having done this project
now the second thing is you'll get also
rid of your perfectionism which might
sound like the same thing
and they do intersect a lot but what i
find is that um
people even people who do make stuff
they're so afraid they're so afraid of
putting out something that's not
perfect and that's actually a real
really big detriment
to like their overall improvement
because look
creative work it's honestly it's a lot
like a sport
you just get better at it over time and
can you imagine if like
a soccer player was refused to kick the
ball
because he said no no i don't want to
kick it imperfectly it's like no
that's actually how you get better at it
and the reality is you never learn
what sticks until you throw a lot of the
things at the wall here's a little quote
i enjoy about a perfectionism
perfectionism may look good in his shiny
shoes but he's a little bit of an
and no one invites him to their
pool parties
it's a nice way of saying perfectionism
looks great is terrible
for creative work now the third thing
i'm going to say that you get out of
going daily
is that the rhythmic nature of uploading
gets you out of your head about how the
video is doing one big problem that a
lot of
new creators new artists new musicians
have
is they look at like especially their
starting work as like everything has to
be a masterpiece and the reality is
it won't all be a masterpiece and one
thing that like
just getting into a rhythm does is it
kind of
uh gives you the option to decouple
yourself from like
how did this video do how did this video
do was it the greatest video i've ever
made it's got to be the greatest video
i've ever made otherwise i won't upload
like
going daily just gets you into this
rhythmic swing where it's like honestly
i can't pay attention to yesterday's
video because
hey we got to work on today's like
that's it done
finished hey if last video was a bomb
hey i got another swing today
if today's video was great doesn't
matter i gotta swing tomorrow
but there are problems okay it look
don't let anyone tell you that like hey
just go daily man it's it's like the
same thing as
you know making weekly content it's not
i mean
all creators who go daily will tell you
and even right now like
i am for a while there i i think this
was the first weekend
i took off in four months and that
really can mess with you and i think one
of the problems is is that like
in this hustle in this like pursuit of
being better at what you do
you can end up sacrificing your
longevity
by getting burnt out early on and i
think casey neistat's a great example of
this
of how you know you can be doing very
well going daily and still burn out
because
you just have zero time to recharge
and not only that every moment of your
life is like devoted to
it you're just obsessed with like the
next video you know what i mean
all i was thinking about all the time
was my work 24 7.
so when i wasn't doing my work i was
pretending
like the time we hung out we first met
you came by my studio
all i was thinking about then is like
okay how do i parlay this into content
for my
episode for today yeah and it wasn't me
that doesn't mean i wasn't excited to
meet you or happy to be around you but
the reality was that was going
on yeah and then you start to push that
your kids like come on hang out with my
kids all how can i make this moment
something vloggable
hang on my wife how can i make this
vloggable without her knowing
and you start to go crazy and it
makes those experiences also pretty
hollow
exactly yeah and then it starts to make
you hollow now for this next con
let's go back to the board okay uh or
sorry the conspiracy board here guys
please okay because the next thing i
want to tell you
about you should know you will have to
put out videos that you know
are not your best work and it's not easy
to do if you're someone who takes pride
in their work
um and it's not because you're trying to
give people bad things it's literally
that's the
best you can do in 24 hours now the
opposite is also true that you'll have
days where you just like
you make a great piece of content in 24
hours that you can like stand behind
and you think is as good as what you
could make in in a month
like i mean i look at my my video on
james arthur ray
where i interview uh the grieving mother
of the of the her daughter that james
ray killed
in a sweat lodge that interview had me
in tears
and i still i would hang my ad on that
interview any day of the week
i you know we have the j mazzini
investigation that is an amazing
serialized arc
but not everything can be like
that exciting that level of content
and that's just the reality and you know
something that i think of i was thinking
about stephen king he's one of my
favorite authors you know
like he wrote one of my all-time
favorite books lisey's story
and i wish i could tell you that all of
stephen king's
books are great but they're not if
you've ever looking through steven's
back catalog
dude some of them okay just going to be
honest honestly steven some
suck but the reality is that you know
when you i later read his book on
writing
you learn that oh this is a pro this is
a process
sometimes you feel inspired sometimes
you have all the great ideas
sometimes you don't it's the same guy
but
part of the work is just like pumping
out content
and not being overly judgmental about
is this the best work i've ever done or
is this just more practice
for me to write my next inspired work
and not everyone
has to live by that by the way i think
there are a lot of people who they
only ever want to let great things into
their catalog
and i think that's a whole content
strategy i think that's fine
it's much more like the george rr martin
model where it may take you much longer
to get a book series out like like your
epic
work you know and you may want to take
years and years to do that but
at the end of the day it is just a
different frame you will see these like
two content styles butt heads from time
to time
even in one interview i think george r
martin explicitly just asked like how do
you write so fast to stephen king
and i think the answer is they just have
two different formulas
for their own work is there anything
that you've always wanted to ask me
yes yes there is something i want to ask
you all right
how do you write so many books so fast
i actually think that layered within
this like
hilarious exchange is a really deep
divide between like two
approaches to making stuff if all you
ever wanna make
is like perfect things you will be
like george rr martin wondering how the
people
who are more willing to just like sort
of grind out every day
how they get so much stuff done and i
think both are valid
ways of approaching the creative process
but i think i find myself
more comfortable with the stephen king
model just
personally now the last thing we're
going to have to go to the board for
ladies and gentlemen we're gonna have to
go
uh to the board to tell you about
because
this is the sad truth of daily uploads
for those of you
who wanna know and this is probably the
part that will disqualify a lot of
people
and probably the reason that i'm going
to kind of cut back
on daily vlogging or daily vlogging
daily uploading a bit which is that
prepare to never see your family
okay that is a rule of making daily
content you just
don't have time this is an interview
between pete holmes and jon stewart
uh obviously the famous host of the
daily show where they talk about this
he represents sort of the daily grind by
the way i just want to know how you
balance an actual life with this mania
pete you you really don't that's that's
the secret here
is uh surrender you're on your way to
being a shell of a man
all i can say is welcome to the team
it's a funny way of putting
a hard truth which is that um a lot of
the youtubers that i've seen
go daily i mean it is like it's hard
on them it's harder than family because
you're just non-stop crying you're just
non-stop uh which is why today i'm
telling you guys that this is
this is not forever i'm gonna just my
new commitment to you is that i will
make videos
when i feel like making them and it will
probably be pretty frequently because i
have a blast doing this
i just and i love like just being able
to get out my my thoughts
regularly but i'm not gonna be
this like youtube's fun i like you guys
don't love you i love my family and
that's
and my friends and all that kind of
stuff so
for me when i look at this and i think
about daily uploads
i think that's a part of it that's a
part of the the dark bargain
is that you know you get a lot done
you're incredibly
you can be incredibly creative you get
to iterate through ideas
by the way something we didn't talk
about a good thing is like you get
better at this thing of like making
videos
so much faster i i don't know i didn't
leave with this by the way it's like one
of the greatest pros
then if you had just made uh you know a
video week of video month
like this is you if you're daily you're
just constantly taking
more swings at the uh at the proverbial
algorithm
than anyone else is and i think that's
you know you learn a lot
but it's a dark bargain voice so yeah
that's what i've learned from daily
uploading for the past 100 days
starting now i'm taking weekends off and
that's it if i can get seven videos done
in five days
that's great if not sorry like
this is i'm in it for the marathon and i
don't want to be
you know like um casey neistat talking
about
burnout and like i think he's changing
careers but
i mean the reality of burnout is once
you're burned out like that's
you can't really it's hard to get back
in the saddle so for now
i think uh yeah maybe a few less videos
maybe a few more videos on coffee break
thanks for watching and i will see you
guys tomorrow
wake up and smell the coffee